this site includes two huge temples and
statues of an ancient ruler for four
points it looks like Mexico is going to
try for four and Canada is trying for
four alright and you're trying for five
I know I saw you put your car down
alright
Mexico's in the lead with 30 USA has 27
Canada has 25 so we'll start with Canada
what did you put down Petra Petra what
did you put down
Abu Abu Simbel Mexico what did you put
down
Abu Simbel losing been correct response
Abu Simbel
34 points total for Mexico gutsy move by
Canada that didn't pay off
four points more for the United States
takes them to 31 they will finish in
second place to the first time winners
from Mexico and a round of applause if
you will ladies and gentlemen to all of
the other competitors who are in the
stands here today we travel for many
parts of the world to compete in this
world championship